this is where I live this is my home
office and I work from home on a couple
of different things I write a blog not
that often anymore hi I ride an iPhone
app called overcast and I have a podcast
called the accidental tech podcast and I
do all that from here I think almost
everybody would mention three things
that I haven't been working on for quite
some time which would be that I was the
kind of maybe co-founder if not first
employee of tumblr and then I made
instapaper and after that I made the
magazine none of which I am involved
with anymore my main job was to make it
work and to make it fast for its first
four years or so
I contributed little minor feature
things here and there I might have been
responsible for its gift support or Jif
depending on who you ask
but for the most part David David Karp
the founder he was the idea guy and he
was the front-end designer and he would
he is also a programmer so he would do
like a lot of the front-end programming
I was doing like the backend stuff
making the server's work making things
fast optimizing things database stuff
you know that like the kind of hard core
programming stuff that was my job I was
like the stage crew of tumblr you know
like that making things work but no one
really notices my job I look back on it
kind of the way I look back on college
it's like it's something it's a thing I
did I had a good time doing it but now
it's I mean I left there five years ago
now and it was such like a whirlwind of
craziness of just this thing that was
growing incredibly and we had to be
keeping up with it and I had to be you
know trying to make the site scale and
everything and it was so much stress so
much work I enjoyed it I do look back on
it fondly but it's also I feel like I've
like moved past the stage in my life
where I can do things like that ever
again and yeah I definitely only want to
look back on it I did occasionally want
to be like the guy who was in the
spotlight being recognized as like the
celebrity of the site but not most of
the time most the time I was very happy
being just the person who made things
work very well because that was very
challenging the company was growing like
crazy and we had kept the staff really
really small at too small for too long
and it was about to explode into what
like my job was about to become a whole
department of lots
people and I neither wanted to manage
sexual Department nor would I be
qualified to because I have no
management experience so I would neither
be qualified to manage so many people
nor would I want to work under someone
else managing him so so that's when I
decided you know what David and I both
are like yeah this is a good time let's
let's leave while while we're still
happy with each other and our jobs so we
left on great terms and yeah I still
talk to David today and we're
everything's great and you do you follow
tumblr much like look do you Samba I
don't really use it much I'm like I will
I still have my account I still have the
app on my phone and I will jump in from
time to time browse and see you
know seek some things if I want if I'm
looking for something to read or browser
you know just waste some time with but I
don't really publish there anymore
because my like most of my geek
community uses Twitter as the primary
place where they gather so it's just
it's kind of just like not where my
friends are anymore well one of the
reasons why I decided to leave when I
did was that I already built Instapaper
and it was already doing pretty well and
it could support me full-time at that
point and I knew that if I if I took it
over as my full-time job
that I could make it even better and I
and I could you know I could make it you
know I could make it a thing the thing I
did I could work for myself and work
from home which I had never been able to
do before I had never even considered
the possibility and now I had this great
opportunity to take this thing I was
doing at night in my free time which was
dwindling to do this thing at night to
take that full-time was incredibly
exciting and satisfying so I went right
into doing that full-time what level of
enjoyment do you get from that kind of
constant refinement and iteration and
improvement and fixing things as as
everything changes versus creating
something brand new is one more
enjoyable than the other they're
different they're different
satisfactions you know like I think you
need a healthy balance of both to be
happy as a programmer a lot of
programmers only love the creating new
things part and that that can be
challenging when you're tasked with some
boring task because even when you're
creating something new there's like 10%
of it that's actually that new exciting
part and then the other 90% of it is all
the boring stuff you have to do to make
that into something that you can use or
sell or really
case so it I feel like you have to kind
of develop an appreciation for both and
really they both are satisfying in
different ways like I love being able to
go in and delete old code that is no
longer necessary because some some
change happened you know Apple added
some new things so then I don't lead my
own version of it anymore so I can go
and delete a bunch of code I love that
it feels like you're cleaning like
spring cleaning you know it feels it
feels like you're getting lighter
there's less stuff you have to maintain
and worry about so really both can be
satisfying where is that tipping point
when do you let go when do you let
instapaper go when do let Magazine go
when you let any project go sometimes
it's forced upon me you know like the
magazine didn't really work out it
wasn't it was not doing well under my
stewardship so I sold it somebody who
wanted to work on it Instapaper
was somewhat similar it was doing well
still but I was no longer able to give
it the amount of time and attention it
needed and so I you know I just had to
move on to new things and to sell or
shut down my old things when in short I
no longer want to work on them or I no
longer can work on them that can that
can occur if it fails that can occur if
the market changes that can occur if my
if my personal situation changes if I
have more or less time to devote to
certain things or if I just have a
really awesome idea of something else I
want to do instead and that doesn't
happen very often most of my ideas are
terrible and I can recognize that early
on that you know what this idea that I
thought was really cool that I should
not do that because he even the things
that I released it have been terrible
you haven't seen the other hundred ideas
I had that were way worse than those
you've got a job that I think would
appeal to a lot of people what have you
been able to get away this such a cool
thing I think it's a combination I mean
certainly there has been some luck along
the way I'm not going to deny that but
it's also a combination of just being in
the right place at the right time like I
was a little too young I graduated from
college in 2004 so I missed like the
first web.com wave and if you were in
that at all you had a pretty good chance
of being good at something or or winning
or being successful at something you
know you had a pretty good chance
whereas if you know if I was in iOS apps
at the very beginning which I was you
know 2007 there
that was the first iPhone and the app
strop and in 2008 I was making apps on
day one in the App Store I'm Instapaper
1.0 was in the store right then at the
beginning and I've been making apps now
as long as somebody could make iphone
apps and so timing you know just being
being in the market when it's taking off
is a huge advantage and then beyond that
it's just I just keep doing it I mean
I've been trying to build an audience
for over a decade I've been I've been
blogging for over a decade now you know
I've been making apps for what seven
years or whatever it is so it's really
it's a combination of those things you
know some of its look some of it is
being in the right place at the right
time and some of it is just a long span
of hard work I started blogging in like
2002 or something I mean not well at all
but but i-i've been writing for a long
time like that I started blogging more
seriously in about 2006 2007 and just
been doing it since then and that has
evolved with the apps like when the apps
came out no one looked at my blog my
blog had no audience I wasn't even on
Twitter Twitter it and actually just yet
I don't think or it just barely and and
so everything has kind of grown together
it helps to have all those things
because I'm like people who find my blog
are then more likely to get my apps
people who know my apps first are more
likely to read my blog now I have a
podcast and the podcast is getting
popular in part because I started it
after I'd built these audiences and in
part because again the same effect I
have people who download the app might
be interested in my podcast because they
like the app people who like the podcast
will go buy the app so it's it's this
nice I hate to say synergy I'm sorry but
it really is kind of the synergy of of
these reciprocating forces that really
do help that you know if you build them
up together and again this all takes
time I mean I've been podcasting for
five years I've been blogging for 10 at
least some like that I've been making
apps as I said for a you know seven or
whatever so it just takes a long time to
build up these things for most people
but that is kind of part of the fun of
it you know it's it's the whole step
along every step along the way every
time I would get like wow I guess made a
post I got
thousand views like every step along the
way then next time I'm gonna do a big
post it gets 10,000 like every one of
those has been exciting and awesome and
something I never thought possible
beforehand and that's on a screen called
nitpicky details every time I do things
like this I think it's a risk and I
think maybe it'll turn off some people
first of all and every time I tell the
objects around the character so now he's
back to his original facing direction